Speaker 1: Let's hear from some people in
the audience. We take calls on the Friday
show via Discord. You can find the discord
at David Pakman dot com slash discord. The
discord is free. It is free to join. It
is free in every way. And it is how you
can reach me. Let's hear from some folks
starting with Britney in Austin. Britney,
bye. Correct that. That's Austin, Texas.
Speaker 3: Yeah, that's.
Speaker 1: Correct. Welcome to the show.
Speaker 3: Good. I'm assuming you can hear
everything fine.
Speaker 1: Oh,
you're coming through perfectly a little bit
echoey, but I'm guessing, you know, in, like
an Italian shower or something like that echo.
Speaker 3: Really? That's really weird. Okay,
well, I know you stated that many times you
believe the Justice Department should prosecute
Donald Trump if the evidence points to illegal
behavior. Sure. But I worry about a scenario
where they do prosecute, but ultimately the
evidence just isn't sufficient enough to convict
and how the end result could play out for
negatively for Americans to like. And Donald Trump
is accused of crimes that ultimately result in a
lack of conviction for those crimes. I think this
could be potentially catastrophic because right
now with the work from the January six Commission,
while Donald Trump isn't formally convicted
of anything, we all know that. We all know and
understand his role in attempting to subvert,
subvert a democratic election. But if a case
is presented and none of the charges stick, I'm
worried that public perception may shift about
January six, and Republicans could use this as an
opportunity to try similar things in the future
and under the guise that it wasn't
illegal and it wasn't. I was just curious.
Speaker 1: I tend to agree with you, Brittany, I
think and this is why I've said if the evidence
points in that direction, that is the most
important thing. If the evidence justifies
and it. Listen, prosecutors, it's not like we
need to tell prosecutors, you should really only
do this if you think you can get a conviction
or at least a plea deal on guilty. That's how
prosecutors operate. They understand that.
And sometimes it's to a fault and sometimes
cases aren't prosecuted because prosecutors have
limited time, limited resources, and they want to
get wins. So that's a known issue. But all of that
being said, I agree with you. If Trump is charged
and there is not even like a guilty plea deal
or whatever slap on the wrist, you've got to
at least get that. If you don't get that, if
you have an acquittal or charges are dropped,
it it is an absolute and total disaster. They will
use it for a decade and it will set everything
good back for a very long time and put at risk
future elections, as you astutely point out.
Speaker 3: Yeah, prosecution aside, I definitely
think that we need to make sure the case is
strong enough before we support prosecuting,
because I just get really worried about those
charges not sticking, but answering my question.
Speaker 1: How is Austin these days? You know,
Austin is a popular target for people to say,
oh, it's ruined. The Liberals have ruined Austin.
Speaker 3: I mean, I love Austin. It's the
only place in Texas I would live. Right. Me,
too. I'm not into the. Into the government,
but it's really hot. So just be aware of that.
Speaker 1: All right, Britney,
thank you so much for the call.
Speaker 2: Sure.
Speaker 1: There is Britney from Austin, Texas